[Music]
this fuzzy little creature is a quacker
and these guys live here off the west
coast of australia on rottnest island
quakers are not only cute they are
camera ready and they're taking the
internet by storm
[Music]
so let's start at the beginning what is
a quacker a quacker is a small wallaby
uh it comes from the same family as a
kangaroo and physically they've got
thick brown fur they've got long tails
and they hop around
quackers thrive on rottnest island
because they don't have any predators
over here so there's no foxes we have
the largest viable population of about
ten thousand oh sorry and you are my
name's cassiana gray and i'm a
conservation officer on rottnest island
in my role i'm responsible for managing
conservation programs and there's one
online trend that has really helped
these animals a caucus selfie but make
sure you're getting it right
how to take a quacker selfie
step one a camera
step two a quacker
but don't touch the quackers
ah
no
or feed them it's 150 fine
these guys don't need the food they
naturally graze their way through the
island's vegetation and they also really
love the seedlings that we plant as part
of our re-vegetation projects that we
have implemented by our environment
technicians sorry about that guys thanks
for all your hard work
and what makes these guys so great for
taking selfies
around the settlement area the quackers
are a lot friendlier they've become used
to people so their natural behaviours
change but out in the reserve where
they're actually still exhibiting their
natural behaviour they will be a lot
more wary of people we have to know are
they actually smiling in photos yeah
they're not actually smiling in the
photos it's just the natural shape of
their mouth which comes up at the side
which
makes them look like they're smiling
the popularity of the quack selfie has
given us the opportunity to be able to
raise awareness about the quakers
particularly on the mainland that are
under threat
so we use that as a platform to educate
the public and also educate them about
appropriate interaction with wildlife so
finally a good cause for selfies
[Music]
you